the world faces a major crisis in drug
development few new drugs are coming on
stream and many old ones are ceasing to
work the laureate whose work with x-ray
crystallography has been very important
for drug development is brian kobilka
these proteins are really cool these are
the g-protein coupled receptors they're
the proteins that allows cells to
communicate with the outside world and
send signals to other cells and they're
really important in drug development to
a lawyer to crystallize the ribosome a
breakthrough also crucial for medical
research is adriana's this is one of the
most complicated machines in all of
nature we all learned about it in high
school biology class but we're only now
is starting to understand how it really
works and her works key to understanding
antibiotic resistance
the topic of our discussion should be
antibiotic resistance we have to do
something about it otherwise we're gonna
have a huge antibiotic resistance
pandemic my hypothesis is even worse
than yours I think that two three
decades and we come back to the middle
of last century before antibiotics about
a divided about middle of last century
antibiotics came into the game we are
stepping to that side if the situation
continues is now it's already starting
with tuberculosis if you know about the
resistance to tuberculosis in hospitals
not in hospitals in hospitals mrs a but
um I mean tuberculosis is also problem
but in developing countries many people
blame the hospitals to increase the
level of resistance and it may be
correct and because that's the way it is
but tuberculosis says a lot of
resistance and they are not too many
hospitals in Africa so in there is not
abused of of antibiotics in Africa
because they can't just do this they
don't they don't feed their cattle with
antibiotics because they can't afford it
so still there is resistance it's much
more than just hospitals this is why I
jumped on you the resistant goes because
bacteria want to live and they know how
to do it then and there there a
generation time few hours so they do in
one week what we do in a hundred years
did you hear about motive he died from
infectious disease before being 40 did
you hear about Japan schubert they all
died very young from infectious diseases
we may be able to continue sbr now oh we
can go back to what happened then on one
side we don't have any new drugs but on
the other side the drugs the drugs that
we do have we're not working so slowly
the noose is tightening around
and unless we do something about this I
think she's right and we're too
complacent I think in new drug
development so i don't know if it's
obviously scientists i think within the
scientific community its accepted that
there is antibiotic resistance problem
but the general public I don't sense
this urgency the same time like where is
worthy academics and working on this
problem I mean I will look around
Stanford everyone's working on cancer
you know I don't even work on cancer and
people say are you working on cancer
among people who I consider my peers so
graduate students and postdocs working
on cancer that's considered very
prestigious right working on antibiotic
resistance like you kind of like you
know raise your eyebrows a little bit
when you hear something doing that I
mean it's like who funds that work I'm
surprised yeah I think it's a problem a
big problem and I think I think the
general community recognizes it and in
fact if you're treating patients with
cancer you're reducing their immune
function as a resident I took care of
many patients who catch patients need
more antibiotics more often than not
they so it might be the case in your
experience at Stanford but I think it's
still very everybody recognizes that are
very important a Fergie agree with you
said that there's a huge problem the
pipeline is dry there knew that the
number of approved drugs you know it's
getting lower and lower every year so
there must be something wrong with the
way things are being many more people
are being born of with the es the
process of drug discovery has been
rather disappointing and in fact we
really haven't seen much of an advance
this diagram shows the amazing attrition
rate in going from the drug discovery
process for every five thousand to ten
thousand compounds that make the drug
discovery stage only one will actually
reach FDA approval the process takes 10
to 15 years and the cost is about eight
hundred million dollars just to develop
that one drug it's clear that there
needs to be more research done on
antibiotic resistance and new drug
discovery
it's just not really profitable anymore
uh-huh so doesn't matter if people die
young yeah because they just don't find
it profitable and is it because of the
high cost of drug discovery or it's the
high cost of the pills that they can
sell to a little people and the
cheapness of antibiotics and roll so
they make the accounting based on just
now right but if it goes like it is just
now in 20 years they won't have patience
so is there a way to make it cheaper I
don't know but I discussed it with many
companies and they say that the cost of
of making a drug is immaterial because
people that will buy it will pay for it
what they want to show that they grow
the company is great that they have a
new compounds for the very difficult
diseases like cancer and alzheimer and
so on the cost is is my know we
frequently hear that forty percent of
all pharmaceuticals target GPCRs what
are these drugs doing why do we have any
clue or it's it's entirely serendipity
and then we found out sort of like after
the fact that they involved GPCRs
g-protein coupled receptors are a large
family of membrane proteins that are
responsible for communication between
cells in the body they act by being
located on the surface of the cell they
detect the hormone and neurotransmitter
floating on the outside of the cell and
transmit that information to a g-protein
or other signaling proteins on the
inside of the cell and in doing so they
change the behavior of the self the fact
that they're responsible for responding
to most hormones and neurotransmitters
they are therefore targets for drug
discovery for most cases they can find a
drug that will bind the equipment
problem is finding a drug that does the
right thing one defines in GPCRs and
even even knowing what it is they're
looking for us sometimes a problem at
least recently that they've been very
targeted and focused they know they're
working on GPCRs it's just that some of
the off target effects they're not so
sheriff and probably the most successful
drugs are drugs that have been around
for a long time if you're really
interested you should read the
biography of Sir James black and how we
develop propranolol in the first h2
blockers uh-huh this is like 110 years
ago no this many years ago music sorry
yeah well then your life reviewing it
I'm revealing again yeah yeah even hold
in my life oh wow okay oh wow light with
proteins their structure and codes their
function and so in order for us to have
a very molecular picture about how
proteins work and how we can create
molecules to interact with them in the
way that we want it helps to have a
complete detailed picture of what it
looks like and that's exactly what we
can get with x-ray crystallography in
the idea this technique is if you can
take a molecule even a very complicated
one like a protein and get it to form a
crystal then we have the ability to
shoot x-rays at it and the precise way
in which those x-rays it bounced off it
and come back can be used to reconstruct
a three-dimensional picture of what the
protein is doing the structure is
obviously very difficult i mean you both
spent years and years crystallizing and
this is not an easy task but it's such
an important tool and drug discovery do
you think that we will ever get to the
point where we could kind of streamline
this process it's likely that even
though membrane proteins for example are
very difficult to crystallize that it
will be possible in the next number of
years because we're already getting much
better at doing it I think there will be
ways of integrating that in drug
discovery and at least to help optimize
the process I come from a tropical
country I live in the Philippines and
you know i do very classical natural
products chemistry I'd really want to
ask if you think that biodiversity
exploring biodiversity still has a role
in drug discovery or is it completely
out of the picture a plant is a complex
mixture there's probably hundreds
thousands of molecules in there so what
you do is you separate them from each
other then you purify them you get pure
compounds which can then be tested for
some activity for example
they kill bacteria or you know they
alleviate inflammation many of the drugs
available on the market now have our
natural products themselves or derived
from natural products that's true I mean
erythromycin took a cyclist that's right
where did the antibiotics it's a gold
mine I think it is you drive it and the
idea is that nature has already had to
solve these problems like nature has had
to deal with like killing nasty bacteria
so you're saying instead of like
reinventing the wheel let's take
advantage of what evolution that's
exactly exactly he's a problem with the
chemical libraries right now they
consist of relatives of current drugs so
a lot of the compounds are related to
compounds that already exists right and
they're they're made they consist of
things that can be made relatively
easily and what you're talking about in
nature are often compounds that are very
difficult to make and very hard to make
things things you wouldn't naturally
include in a library it's as good as any
other level it may be even better
because the humanity was not exposed to
them much if they are special why the
hell did the plans have this product why
the plants produce compounds that can
stop the growth of bacteria and I think
that this is their immune system it is
it is they should police antibacterial
to losing even in the Philippines
medicinal plants play still a very
important role in primary health care we
still use some herbs for for cough for
example for for diarrhea and also my
grandmother didn't it worked it worked
right yes it worked like I don't say
grandmother big because I'm a and making
fun of fail the opposite it works and
the thing is there seems to be a
resistance from the medical community as
if it gets too much hocus-pocus yeah
yeah yeah and then some of us have to do
the validation some of us have to show
that these things I mean it's been used
for several hundred years right they
seem to work not for all diseases okay
we should admire nature yeah yes I don't
think there's any one single approach
that's going to solve all the problems
but it's my hope that having access to
more structures for g protein-coupled
receptors
will at least facilitate the process and
maybe reduce some of the expense of the
process but I think one thing where we
all agreed is we definitely feel as
scientists that for the next generation
we're going to do a better job if you
really understand stuff and actually
design it as opposed to just guess as
crystallographers who you know I've done
like incredibly wonderful work do you
feel an obligation to use this
information to inform medicinal related
research or do you still feel very
strong about trying to address basic
questions about the respective proteins
that you've worked on so I think we're
trying to go both paths so first of all
I should say I'm not I don't consider
myself a crystallographer I think I
think most crystallographers would not
consider me at this low part of our
research effort now would be to try to
develop ways to apply what we're
learning by structural biology to drug
discovery there's a high priority for
you you would say it's a high priority
and I think it's also I hope there's a
certain amount of innovation that's
involved as well so I will answer you
not as a crystallographer but as a
scientist of course crystallography is
the method that I think gives that the
information at the molecular level but
it's not the only method it's not the
only information and it's not my only
mission very important for me is to talk
to people like your young people even
younger than you in order to to inspire
work even if it's long speaking to Nobel
laureates this week it's been really
inspiring to me to see how these people
saw themselves in a similar life they
saw themselves as basic scientists they
weren't trying to solve the world's
problems and just happened to work out
that way and for me it's been very
encouraging you know as a basic
scientist to say you know these are
people you know where their science
really change the world maybe that'll be
us